hey guys I'm Ryan right hey guys I'm
Jerry we're gonna check out the trailer
for a film that Jerry already saw the
green band for it's Michael Bay's new
movie yeah I was shocked by the starring
I think John Krasinski's in this 13
hours the secret soldiers of Benghazi
said it right birds need Michael Bay
Birds son to protect CIA op who's the
personnel unstable regions 2012 the
threat level in Benghazi
[Music]
Libyan visa official but overall for
inspectors sorry sir I can't do that
pull over for inspection I want you to
die for your country I'm gonna go right
here right now
[Music]
all right everybody this is Jack Silva
jack we trained seals at Coronado so he
knows the drill
welcome to club man
[Music]
we recruit we are overrun
stay under attack
[Music]
the US ambassador at risk the Ambassador
is India's safe haven you're not the
first responders with a last resort hey
you will break it
none of you have to go we are the only
help they have
[Music]
time to kick some ass know when
everything went wrong I came you're not
giving orders anymore
during my well done we have 36 American
lives to say
[Music]
January interesting huh oh um I mean I
was surprised that was Michael Bay the
first time I saw it I did not know
really it shot like a Michael Bay film
yeah but it is Morse it like it it just
seems like it's more serious than any
Michael Bay movie it doesn't seem like
it's fun at all well there was a time
where a lot of his films were action
errs but they were very serious yeah
yeah maybe it's just because movies like
these that are about very relevant very
very modern warfare are kind of jarring
and upsetting to me I'm worried Michael
Bay's gonna try a little too hard well
Michael Bay already made like especially
the Transformers like they're very
jingoistic and so I'm curious as to how
natural this is gonna play versus how
like really good like red-blooded
American this yeah play cuz I mean
that's a sensitive topic that's that's
where I'm a little concerned because I
that's what I mean by Michael Bay is
gonna probably try too hard to actually
maybe get these political points and
like I'm gonna show it could be a
meaningful director right now but then
he's gonna get caught up in action
sequences it's a good trailer the
knowing Michael Bay movies prior to
transformers and knowing how his
trailers would go down yeah that's what
I'm predicting from this the main reason
I will watch this if any is because of
John Krasinski yeah he does I admit at
first I was like I kind of want to make
an office joke right now because he's
all bearded up and serious by where Jim
went after day yeah I'm looking at this
footage only he looks he looks like a
badass he looks like he's gonna do a
well that's what I'm curious about
because this movie doesn't look badass
in the same way that other Michael Bay
movies have like a badassness like it
does look you know at least from this
trailer like immediate and like you know
this is we're doing what we have to do I
don't necessarily trust Michael Bay when
a movie like this but that being said
you know it's like we've sort of seen
this before it's like I believe if you
give Michael Bay a good script he can
make a good
and the way it's shot like it certainly
puts you right there you know and
there's nothing to suggest otherwise
anywhere on this trailer it all seems
like you're right in the room for
everything and and that can be very
jarring ya know this looks like a it
looks like a dramatic political thriller
it doesn't feel like Michael Bay
entertainment yeah I know so I'm curious
but but it could just be a really well
cut trailer I'm curious but I'm not
exactly consciously out that's how I
feel about Michael Bay and Zack Snyder
movies they get the best [ __ ]
trailers every Transformers trailer I
have fallen asleep at a three out of the
four Transformers movie yeah and every
Transformers movie that comes out I'm
like this looks like it's gonna be a
really good Transformers movie yeah yeah
they get trailers and so I don't and
it's a January movie not saying only bad
movies come out in January but usually
bad movies come out in January yeah I'm
curious about that too is like do they
put it there just because there's
nowhere else to put it exactly like
maybe it's real maybe like worst-case
scenario maybe it's really well done but
it's not quite heavy enough like maybe
zero dark thirty already covered this in
a more qualitative way yeah I don't know
how to feel right now because you know
it's like the Transformers movies the
trailers always look really great
because it's what makes the trailers
look good and what makes the movies not
work is like they're taking themselves
so seriously so the trailers and it
works for two minutes but for almost
three hours you're like stop taking
yourself so that's what I mean by
Michael Bay trying to use already this
movie is like it's this is a real
situation worth taking seriously though
yeah Michael Bay is very patriotic
but in like a an aggressive bro II kind
of like [ __ ] yeah merica kind of way
like it's kind of abrasive because
Transformers movies are very much like
that and very jingoistic so I don't know
Gail from Breaking Bad is in there
that's who is that really Gail that's
Gail I'll never forget Gail oh yeah I'll
watch it again just so I can make Gail
jokes about Breaking Bad and the office
crossing over I want to be the dunder
mifflin manager Dwight I want your
bobblehead yeah okay you brought up zero
dark thirty earlier
yeah zero dark thirty was really real
you know really real and it also had a
certain level of Jenny to me anyway it
felt genuine it didn't feel swayed in
one you know message direction or the
other it didn't feel overly right or
left wing and just felt kind of natural
I may be being too hard here but it just
feels a little overdramatized and I feel
that this is so [ __ ] into yeah I feel
like they hide it up a lot of the
actions because this is based on a true
story yeah yeah so I feel like they
probably really amped up the action
sequences as opposed to what happened in
real life
something tells me that's what's gonna
happen more propaganda Michael Bay
thank you that's what I'm worried about
right now cuz Michael Bay is good and
like there's some manipulative imagery
in there too like the whole like oh the
American flag yeah and like you know I
feel like any wartime situation is a
little more you know difficult to sift
through than just like [ __ ] you America
the cinematography that looks great it
really does look amazing ya know Michael
Bay I mean it's got some signature
Michael Bay shots you know the sweeping
shot the lighting looks similar but
everything is sweating
yeah everything's really sweaty so he's
like so hot I'm like oh baby Michael Bay
must write all or you know like you know
do all of his thinking and script
breakdowns in a sauna
oh yeah just comes up with all his ideas
in his sweat box I'm already worried
about him in terms of the storytelling
department and now I'm very would this
is like the most worried I would be
about a Michael Bay movie handling its
subject matter I have a feeling this is
gonna be one of those trailers where
people are like this looks good but the
second it says from director Michael Bay
everyone's gonna be like oh blog well
cuz it immediately makes you doubt what
it really makes you go like oh I don't
know there's the problems with the
trailer yeah it's like oh when I'm
watching this I I can imagine I'm gonna
kind of need a shower
yeah his films can sometimes be ahead it
can vary over way too long I just don't
know if I trust him with this material
you know and he's always technically
good he's that he's a technically great
director and the performances look fine
but I don't trust him with subject
matter Larry guys thanks for tuning in
to the channel if you're new to it you
can
drive to the real region or reject our
reasons to Jerry and dank ass dubs
[ __ ] and monkey check out us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine
periscope a more propaganda at Michael
Bay thank you Jack Hogan Jack Hogarth
like the Iron Giant yes please shout me
out JM age 25 17 Jack Hogarth that is
actually a type of oral sex maneuver
what the Hogarth the Jack Hogarth that's
where you're drifting off the penis at
the same time uh-huh
well let me get my notebook yeah so
you're jerking off the penis while
you're blowing it typical right but then
what you have to do is you got to get
into a handstand afterwards so yeah
while your your mouth is on it you got a
like cartwheel into a handstand this is
really complicated and then they got a
and then when they thrust the guy he has
to put his arms out like this and like a
real really obvious hump into the mouth
and until she chokes and then pukes the
jack Hogarth why I don't know some
people are into it man I tried it once